[Music]
recognize these characters these
eyeballs this face they were all made by
the same guy Stan Winston and there's a
way to learn exactly how he brought
these practical effects legends to life
practical effects often get overshadowed
by CGI which can do the seemingly
impossible one school however thinks
that special effects are here to stay
and it's helping teach the craft to the
next generation of artists the Stan
Winston school is an online school based
in Los Angeles where a wide array of
Hollywood special-effects artists have
taught character creation to over 20,000
students since its founding its online
tutorials can be watched either live or
at your convenience classes instruct
viewers how to do everything from
putting feathers on a fake bird to
making a mask to creating a convincing
monster online education allows you to
have the tools at your hands to learn on
your own time the schools named after
this guy Stan Winston and his teachings
and creations greatly influenced
everything about the school he was one
of Hollywood's most legendary
special-effects artists and a pioneer in
the field the school's launched by his
son Matt Winston and son-in-law Erik
gray lid off one of Stan's mantras was
do what you love
follow your passion and success will
come when Steve came to Hollywood with
dreams of becoming an actor when that
didn't work out he ended up in the world
of special-effects even if you don't
know his name you know his work
[Music]
perhaps his proudest achievement was the
Jurassic Park franchise and when she
built dinosaurs both big and small so
this would be one of the claws screen
news cloth from the t-rex in Jurassic
Park along with his many groundbreaking
effects
Winston also managed to film a lot of
his work which the school has in its
archive and often posts online the
school itself is filled with some of
Winston's classics Stan's influences
show up in many of the things it builds
for classes
these are Raptor eyes from the Jurassic
Park series these are hand-painted
clear resin on top of the painted eye
and you can see to give the illusion
there's actually a little bit of depth
between where the paint is and the
urethane is on there teachers will show
you how to make realistic fake eyeballs
in class Winston also built the metal
arm for TX and Terminator 3 rise of the
machines in one of the classes beginners
were taught how to build a very simple
working mechanical arm using just
plumbing parts and stuff you could go
find at the hardware store now
definitely it's very crude but the
principles can be applied to a much more
advanced mechanical hand and this
silicone rod puppet which looks a lot
like this one that was designed for the
movie small soldiers and now with CGI
technology it's easier than ever to
remove the puppeteer remove the rod
sometimes these old pieces are actually
used in lessons in one lesson teachers
use this moving tentacle
which runs on cables attached to a
controller that was used to move and
control the dinosaurs in one of the
Jurassic Park movies the school
emphasizes Stan's philosophy for effects
especially that a lot of influences even
for sci-fi and fantasy puppets and
effects should be rooted in the real
world and nature it's why predator might
have looked so real to you and also how
an instinct they were able to get away
with the gorilla that was actually just
an animatronic mask worn by a guy in a
gorilla suit another major lesson that a
budding special-effects artist must
learn avoiding the uncanny valley which
something appears a little too
frightening ly realistic
if you actually have a puppet on set
physics is now working with you and
natural laws are now working with you
the same light is landing on the puppet
as is on the actor so that heightens the
level of realism the school's also means
of teaching and preserving these methods
a lot of movie special effects sadly
were made just for use on a given movie
and didn't have a long shelf life
oftentimes the materials you need to use
to make sure something is totally
lifelike are very fragile back in the
old days of props and effects and
puppets people didn't really see a value
beyond the filming of the movie and so
many of those things just disappear it
or thrown away
more and more studios are taking great
efforts to preserve these creations and
that's fantastic for everyone because
this really is Hollywood history and and
it's our duty and our honor to play our
part in helping to preserve it and even
though movies today are seemingly
dominated by CGI practical effects
aren't going anywhere
Stan Winston embrace CGI and in movies
he worked on it often went hand in hand
with practical effects for instance in
Jurassic Park in close-ups or any shots
involving interactions with humans the
dinosaurs were usually puppets for wider
shots involving more movement that was
typically CGI he always believed that
the job of an effects artist is to be
invisible you never want an audience to
walk out of a theater going great
effects you want them to say great story
great characters and if you could
achieve that you succeeded for the
famous shot in Jurassic Park where the
t-rex leans down and Lexie shines her
flashlight into his eye and the pupil
dilates a special
device was created to create that
dilating action
[Music]